[Music]
Well, um this is very exciting because
uh I mean 2025 is clearly the year of
agents. Uh compared to the past two
years, things have moved so fast. We
went from very simple uh prompts which
were already incredible but now uh we
move to uh the next step where we have
uh agents that can autonomously uh
achieve goals um without us knowing
exactly how they do that which is quite
incredible. Um but the question is how
do you make them um so that's what we're
going to see today. Um, I am Cedric
Vidal. I am a principal AI advocate at
Microsoft. Uh, you can find my
information down below. Um, and today
I'm gonna be uh your host and um I'm
going to be helped today by proctors uh
by Mark uh and uh I'm sorry I forget
your name. I feel terrible.
Nakmar, did I say it correctly? Okay,
thank you. Um so a big thank you to you
too uh to uh help help me today. So um
during the workshop uh if you have any
question please raise your hand and um
Mark or
argmar
nagmar sorry will help um will come and
help answer uh questions. I feel super
bad. Um anyway, so
um today, like I said, um I'm going to
set the scene first. So what are we
going to uh to do today? So in order to
um put our hands on the keyboard and uh
create an uh and show to you how to
create an agent, uh we're going to use
that use case. Um, imagine that you are
uh working for an outdoor um and hiking
equipment company that sells equipment
online. Um, we are going to So, what you
want to do is you need to um build a
system that allows to analyze your sales
uh data mixed with product information.
Uh, generate ad hoc diagrams. basically
a UX that uh your salespeople can use uh
very easily uh where we move away from
the old paradigma where we had to
hardcode every single use case, every
single view, every single query where
now those uh the database the the
queries are going to be generated
automatically. The UX is going to be
generated automatically to accommodate
the type of information that you are
displaying and we are going to see how
to create such an application.
Um an agent. Okay. Um what is it? Um
because like the definition of an of an
agent has changed so often. Let's be
honest, even the specialists in the
industry don't agree exactly on what
they are. And even the definition of
what an agency is has evolved over time
over the past three years uh as people
have got more acquainted and we're
discovering what we could do with it.
You could you would imagine that a
definition should be set in stone, but
in that case it's been difficult to
agree. But what we're going to the
definition we're going to use today
um is that um it's um semi autonomous
software that uh to which you give a
goal and we'll work to achieve that goal
relentlessly
um using tools and information that you
can pull from databases uh and data data
stores at large and iterate until it
achieves that goal. So until the system
stabilizes and the goal are met,
that's the general uh definition.
But we're going to see that um depending
on the context, they can be uh more or
less simple or complex.
Um in order to do that, an agent should
be able to do three things. uh re do
reasoning um over a provided context to
provide a cognitive function such as
deduction, correlation, understanding
cause and effect all that domain of
cognition. Um the LLM now has proven
that it was able to do a lot of those
not perfectly but it's getting better
every day. Um the second one is
integrate with data sources for context
and the last one is act on the world
because in order to stabilize the system
in order to be useful like before the
first generations of um LLM power system
were just about pulling information and
displaying it but now we are moving a
step forward where we are acting on the
world and modifying the environment
until it stabilizes and reaches uh the
expected goal.
Um
um so what kind of application are we
going to build today? It will look like
this. Um so this is a screenshot of a
slightly different application. What
you're going to build today does not
look exactly like this. But the idea uh
is that you can ask a question in plain
English such as show the sales of
backpacking tents by region and include
a brief description in the table about
each tent. And it's going to it's going
to pull information from the database as
well as the product information and mix
all that information together reason
about it and display the content and the
shape and form of the the display of the
UX will be will depend on the type of
information which is requested. Here
it's a table.
Here it's a pie chart. Uh because the
question here yeah create a pie chart of
sales by region. So um the uh the system
is going to understand that we want to
create a visualization.
Okay. Um what technology are we going to
use today to build our system? We are
going to use Azure AI agents service. Um
the reason um so before I I I dig more
into the details of what this is um you
have so many ways to build an agent
today so many frameworks uh longchain
long graph semantic kernel uh and so
many others um the Azure agent service
um has um the advantage that it's uh
stateful and quite easy to put together
because usually when you build any kind
of LLM application I don't know if
you're aware but it's stateless you need
to manage the state client side so it's
the responsibility of the application
developer to store the conversations to
to uh and to handle all the logic of
pulling information from various systems
as well as executing the functions the
tools
agent service moves all the
responsibility to the cloud uh on the
Azure platform and everything is managed
so um it comes with its pros and We're
going to see what they are. Uh but when
it about the pros um the big advantage
is that it provides um a very um simple
development workflow because all the
state and the context and the agent
configuration is managed in the cloud.
Uh the integration with backend data and
data sources is also managed by the in
the cloud. Even if if you may also mix
and match, you can mix uh things that
are managed um by agent service in the
cloud with things that are managed
locally. It's possible.
Um and it supports all the model
families that are supported on the on
Azure AI model catalog. Uh plus the
Microsoft enterprise security uh which
is very well known to be very robust.
It's sometimes a bit difficult to set
up, but that's a price to pay for
security.
So the application that I just showed
was using um chain lit. The one we're
going to build today is going to be
command line. It's going to be slightly
easier. Uh but so basically at the top
you have um the application layer uh
with the framework. So here chain lit in
our case it's going to become common
line very simple very basic uh with a
query function which is going to use
Azure AI agent uh service uh with
instructions and and models
and uh actions so for function coding
and I'm going to explain what it is a
code interpreter f and I'm also going to
explain what it is file search and
grounding with being searched for web uh
information on grounding
and we're going to go through each one
of those uh during the workshop.
So
like I said um Azure Azure AI agent
service comes with pros and cons. Uh the
pros is that it manage everything for
you. That's a big pro, right? Uh the con
is that you need to understand the
diagram
uh more or less uh you don't need to
understand all the details but um one of
the so I'm going to change side um so
the first thing what is you you're going
to have to follow a sequence of steps um
and you have quite a few steps to follow
in order for agent to work um first you
need to create an agent once you have
created your and configured your agent,
your agent exists in the cloud. It's
kind of weird at first uh because when
you're used to stateless way of doing
things, um that stateful programming
model is not so common those days
anymore. Uh but it becomes um relevant
again in the age of agents. Um, so once
you have your a which means that if
you're you want you have an application
that wants to reuse an agent. If you
have created the agent before, you need
to reconnect to an existing agent. It's
kind of like in SQL like the create or
uh or update table. You only create the
schema if it's if it does not exist uh
yet. Um so it's kind of a create or
update agent for most applications. So
you create the agent,
then you create a thread or you reuse
the thread. Uh then you run the agent on
the thread, then you check the run
status and then you display the agent's
response. Those are the big uh steps
that you need to get familiar with when
building with azure agent service. Um
then you are going to configure
instructions. Um those instructions are
going to be attached to the agent and
they are stateful. So they are uploaded
in the cloud and once they are they are
there you can reuse your agent and you
don't have to send the instructions
every single time. Uh which in terms of
bandwidth the network is interesting.
Um then you configure your model you add
data sources. Um so one of the pros of
using Azure AI agent service is that you
can attach data sources directly to the
agent and you can do that uh either
direct graphically through Azure AI
foundry or you can do that
programmatically through the SDK
uh then you can attach tools uh and
we're going to see how to do that how we
attach each one of those tools. Some of
those tools can be client side. So you
are managed by the application code.
Some of them can be uh managed by Azure.
Today we're going to see uh file search,
code interpreter, function calling, and
being search.
Um
here is an example of a thread of what a
thread looks like. Um so the user's
message is going to be tell me the total
sales by region. Um so what's going to
happen is that in order to get the total
sales by region we need first to get the
sales uh I mean we need to query sorry
we need to query the sales data store
and it happens that in this case the
sales data store is a SQL relational
database and as you know it the way to
interact is using SQL queries. So we are
going to generate a SQL query
dynamically um depending on the user's
request um and then we're going to send
that SQL query execute it on the
database get the list of records back
reinject those records into the LLM
which is going to generate a message in
uh plain text from those uh list of
records. Um, excuse me. Yes, the SQL
light is just for an example. It can be
Yeah, of course. Yeah. Yeah, it's an
example in the in the agent we're going
to build today just because it's
convenient, but you can of course uh
connect it to any database you want
version the document uh in an API like
really doesn't matter uh for the ones
which are managed locally for the ones
which are managed by agent service on
the back end the list is more
restrictive. Uh in to minutes I don't
have it on the top of my mind. Um we're
not going to see any back or sorry we're
not going to see any role access to not
today. Not today. Um it's more it's a
more advanced topic obviously. Uh and it
depends a lot on your use case. Um so
then show as a pie chart which is the
second question we asked in in the
previous screen I showed you. Um this
one is is going to be quite interesting
because we're going to use a a tool
called code interpreter. Um what it does
is that it's going to take the query
generate Python code
and um the Python code is going to be
executed in a sandbox in a secure safe
sandbox. Um and it can be whatever is
supported whatever um package Python
packages are available in the
environment. Usually you use it to
generate um diagrams
um and it's going to generate the Python
code which is going to generate that
visual representation. Uh it's going to
execute the code. The code is going to
save the image somewhere on the file
system inside the sandbox. Then the
agent is going to pull that image out of
the sandbox and send it back to the uh
client application.
Okay. So like I what I said uh this is
quite a lot to uh digest right. Uh but
the thing is you just have to go through
and get a mental model of how that works
and once you understand that uh you
don't have to manage it uh yourself
which is quite um interesting. Does it
use any databases behind the scene
today? or uh uh do we have a vector
database today? Uh I'm blinking. I think
we do. I think we do, but I'm going to
double check. Uh because we ingest the
documents and I think we ingest the
documents inside an AI search instance.
Um
one more very important thing, function
calling.
Um so to be honest function calling is
not new when it comes to LM. I was doing
function calling like literally when the
first version of TDP was announced by uh
asking the LLM to give me uh answers
from separated by commas uh and say
generate a function and an argument
separated by commas. You can still do it
by the way. Uh but nowadays it's much
more efficient. You have structured
output. It generates wellformed JSON.
Even the LLMs are optimized under the
hood. uh inside uh the data center to
generate um op um JSON optim optimally.
Um but so what the principle of function
calling actually the name is bad. I've
hated that name ever since it was uh
coined because it's not function
calling, it's function rooting. The LLM
does not call anything. An LLM runs on a
GPU. It's not going to call any code. Uh
so what it does um rather is that it
generates a JSON representation say
telling you what function to call with
what parameter values and it's going to
map it's going to decide which function
to call and it's going to map the the
natural language sentence and create and
extract um values that it's going to
pass as parameter to the function to be
called and then it's the responsibility
of the application code to take that uh
function uh call specification and
actually execute the code
because that's what it does.
Yes.
[Music]
How does it know? Oh, uh that is an
excellent um that is a very good
question. Um
well it's it's exactly the same uh way
when you ask a question for example when
you ask um what is uh the color of the
sky like very uh one of the first use
cases um obviously the answer is going
to be blue most of the time. Uh the way
lambs uh work is that it's a stat
statistical uh distribution. uh you have
the probability uh that the the word
that comes after when you ask a question
what is the color of the sky the the the
most probable answer is going to be the
color of the sky is and after is the
most probable color is going to be blue
because that's how the model has been
pre-trained right um but if you say what
is the color of the sky and in order to
get me the the answer you only you can
only use um uh for example color equal
and the value of the color
then you give an instruction you tell VM
hey hey here's how here's the output
that I want and then it's going to
generate color equals blue uh just
because you constraint like
statistically in the in the in the world
of all the possibilities uh that you can
um answer it you're narrowing down the
type of output that you want to be
generated. So color equals blue. Imagine
that u and and so you're going to parse
that answer and you're going to
interpret color equals blue and do
whatever you want with it. Except in the
world of function calling it's not color
equals blue. It's set dash. You have a
tool say um execute color which takes a
parameter with the value of the color
and instead of having just one you have
many possible uh functions and same
statistical probabilities. Uh when you
imagine you have one question to set the
color and another function to uh order a
pizza. uh if you ask what the color of
the sky is, it's not going to generate
order pizza call for the same reason.
It's exactly how it works. So how do you
know when function calling versus
creating your own classification model?
Okay. Well, because a classification
model cannot extract values entities uh
out of a context and uh like answer many
many answers across multiple dimensions
at the same time. Uh classification is
just uh one out of n possibilities. Uh
so it's a totally it's an entirely
different type of task.
Okay, let's move on. Um, okay. So, I
want you to uh on your laptops uh to
open the following URL. Uh, so I'm sorry
it's not very big. Uh, I'm going to
spell it. So, uh, Microsoftvents
dot
learnondemand.net.
So Microsoft events all attached
dot events sorry ah my god dot
learnonddemand.net
net.
Is everybody on the page? Okay. Um then
uh you're going to login. Be very
careful. This is very uh important. You
need to choose um Microsoft account.
Well, usually you're going to use um
Microsoft account. Huh. I thought we had
other types of
Okay, so if it's a personal account, you
need Microsoft account. If you have a
corporate account, like if you have a an
account as part of your company uh which
is managed by Entra, you need to select
Entra ID.
So it's it's uh kind of misleading. Do
not select Microsoft account if you use
a corporate account. Use entra ID.
Then
um
you're going to um land on that page.
That page uh you're going to have a
redeem training key um link. Click on it
and then you're going to be asked to
enter a training key. Enter the
following training key.
So hopefully this is big enough and
everybody can see but let me know.
Uh remember uh raise your hands if you
have any questions.
Sorry, what?
Approval.
What?
organization.
Uh you can use also a personal Microsoft
account like uh you can use an
outlook.com, you can use if you have an
Xbox, you can use a an Xbox account, uh
any
Microsoft account or any of the consumer
domains out there.
So in your case you might want to try uh
a personal account
and to be honest in that case today it's
usually uh easier like you you do not
need to use a corporate account today
there is absolutely no need
that first upg
SQL query come back.
Uh you could totally do that. Yeah.
Well, like I say, so the we need to go
back to the definition of what an agent
is. Um and like I said the
so it's a bit of a overloaded term those
days uh it encap encapsulates a wide
range of definition including the
simplest. Today we are not in the
simplest use cases. We are not in the
more complex use cases. For example at
the beginning I said one of the things
that the nation can do is be goal driven
and iterate until it achieves the goal.
Today we are not going to see that
specific thing. We're going to stop one
step. We're going to be in the middle in
terms of complexity. Sorry. Um we are
going to be uh above the simple
completion. Um
uh and we are not going to see the
looping. Um we are going to be we're
going to be seeing a mix of um using
tools and code interpreter with m
multiple data sources where um the
information from all those uh are mixed
together to do reasoning and act on the
world. We're going to see that and yes
you could do that uh using just an LLM
locally. uh nothing would prevent you
from doing that except today we're using
app um service
which uh manages everything server side
also I'm going to show the limits that
today I'm going to give examples to so
that you get a sense and you touch
exactly when
uh the the the current um architecture
hits its limits and when you need to go
further and um and use uh a more
orchestrated um um planning and
orchestration that uh iterates which
which loops until it reaches the goal.
Uh and I'm going to give an example
where you see where it breaks
um
where are we turning key. Uh okay. After
you click on launch
building.
Oh my god.
It's not pre-built.
Okay.
Um, oh my. Um, okay. I thought I thought
they would be pre-built.
Um, did everybody click on the build
button? Okay, please do. Uh, so that
means we have eight minutes to answer
questions.
So, so we just had one. Thank you.
Do Yes, one more. So
if an agent is just an LLM running on a
loop until it thinks that it's done what
you've asked it to do. Yes. How does it
know when to stop? When Yeah. How does
it know what like when to kick kick back
out of that recursion? Yeah. Uh so so
today we are not going to we are not we
are going to see the limits of not um
okay you have two types of agents uh two
levels of complexity.
um an agent does not have to do the
looping to be called an agent in the
simpler uh um area of the spectrum. Um
in order to uh to go one step further
and do that uh that looping you need to
use something like autogen for example.
Um and um those types of agents you need
to define a criteria of done a
definition of done basically. uh and
you're going to have and the criteria
can be implemented uh programmatically
uh deterministically or using an LM
which decides is it done like is the
task finished have we accomplished the
goal and the workflow engine is going to
loop until the goal is reached
um but it is the most tricky thing in my
opinion clearly that's when you're going
to uh develop an agent
figuring out when to stop um is tricky.
For example, um I often uh I've done a
couple prototypes with a browser use
which is a a famous uh open source
agentic system for browser navigation.
uh when you ask it to complete a task on
the web, it's going to navigate from
website to website and read the pages
and do actions and and the evaluation of
when the task is done um is clearly uh
not always perfect.
Um yes,
sorry. One might be related. Yeah,
so my first question is
agent.
You mean the looping? Yeah. So, uh, no.
So, not today. Not today. The other
question is what's in the
agent?
Oh. Uh so it's very easy uh it's a very
easy explanation. So basically MCP is
just a tool a function. You remember I
explained what a function is. So uh an
LM is able to do function routting
decide which function to call when you
have a question.
Um MCP is just that
plus
uh
management of the life cycle of the
program which completes the the which
executes the function.
uh because normal function tooling if
you just take like GPT or llama and um
you do function calling what the LM is
going to return is just a JSON telling
you the function the name of the
function and the list of the values for
each parameter nothing more it's your
responsibility as an application
developer to execute the function
no it's not that you need it's that uh
it's one of the existing technologies
out there that exist that you can use uh
as a tool
And the advantage of MCP uh at least uh
as a client side um AI application
developer um is that the MCP protocol
takes care of downloading the executable
the binary whether it's a node python or
whatever down or a docker image um like
pull the executable on your machine and
execute it automatically
and it's a it's an over protocol which
comes is a uh and also it encapsulates
the possibility for the tool to declare
its uh functions.
Um so uh from the standpoint of the user
you just have to declare oh I want to
use a file system MCP server or I want
to use a blender MCP server or whatn not
and that's all you have to do you can
select it from a catalog and it's going
to auto declare what tools it has and
automatically um start it and stop it
also when you're done with your uh MCP
client. is going to stop all the MCP
servers uh and clean up everything.
Uh is it uh where are we with the
Okay.
Uh
where are we? Oh my god.
Does it give a time? Seven minutes. Oh
my god.
question. Did we forget to do something?
Yeah. Anyway,
I had a question. Yes. Um I was going to
wait and see kind of how the the demo
played out later, but one of the um
questions of I find agents is the
balance between
making a fairly general agent that can
do lots of things and just kind of
giving it the tools, not giving it much
direction versus be fairly controlled
with it. You're kind of trading off the
like autonomy to, you know, a bit of
reliability. The one that you set up
before, I couldn't quite work out if
you've literally just given it the tools
and then it can do everything with those
tools or if you've been quite controlled
with it. So, how do you think about the
trade-off and when people are using your
tools, do they tend to fall more on one
side the other? Uh it's a more complex
answer that um that it looks like more
complex question than it looks like. um
because of two things. Um so when you
give instructions
um you know it's like I was talking
about the uh the the the space of
probabilities
um the more vague you are the more you
you leave uh options open and so the
more um your agent is going to be able
to do wide area wide range of things but
it might get it wrong. the more specific
you are um the more you're restricting
the um the things that it's going to do
well but it's going to do well more
often. Um and then there is you didn't
really ask this but I'm assuming that's
uh on your mind is how many tools can I
uh give to my to my agent. U and also
another common question that we often
get is um
should I um give all my tools to one
agent or should I split tools on
multiple agents or should I create uh
should I only give one tool per agent?
Um and the answer is uh same. It's it's
it's complex but it's kind of um imagine
um same you need to think in terms of um
statistical probabilities like it's it's
stoastic
um and so when imagine you have one
agent and you give all the tools the and
if every single instance for any
question you ask the LM has to decide
which one of all those tools to call the
probability that it gets it wrong is
higher Right.
Um
so the solution to that is to create
agents which are more specialized by
like areas of expertise and do some kind
of routting and multi-step selection
where um instead of having one agent and
giving all the tools you for example you
have a first first round of agent that
is going to determine classify uh we
talking about classification earlier
classify the uh question and say, "Oh,
this is a sales question or this is a a
product question." And then route to an
agent which is more specialized for to
answer things about sales or things
about uh products. Um and then when the
answer comes back, the first agent can
say, "Oh, do I need to use another
agent?" So it's like an agent is like a
multi-tool. So you can imagine like a a
tree of tools and each tool can be
composite or leaf. uh you can see that
way and autogen allow us to build such
um topologies.
Yes.
Each one could be working with a
different data database or different.
Yeah. Yes.
And then the coordinator or the mice to
Yes. Yes. But you can also have
topologies where u the the different
agents share memory because the thing is
um sometimes you also have the situation
where you have uh like a a team of
agents and they are specialized and it's
good that they are specialized because
you don't want to uh them to uh pick the
wrong tool for the reason I just sorry
yeah uh well
because each one has it own. Um yeah,
but what what's going to prevent the
elucination is a grounding. So each one
of those agents is going to be grounded
in something. Uh but something which is
kind some kind of a grounding is memory.
Like for example, if you have uh
multiple tools um that answer questions
about um a consumer um and you want and
you want to memorize remember the
preferences of your consumer of your
user like for example what's the name of
his or her pet and you but you want each
one of your agents potentially to be
able to use that information. So what
you want to do is take that memory,
connect that memory to each one of those
agent. Even if you have multiple agents,
they can each one of them have access to
that shared memory because you want all
of them to be able to access the name of
the pet.
So to be honest, it's complex like you
have many topologies which make sense
depending on your use case.
Where are we?
Ah, finally. Uh so where are we? Is
every Oh, one more. Still building. One
more.
Can Can you please raise your hand when
it's still building?
And how did you train? You refresh or
something else?
Okay. So you can
Okay.
Okay. Hopefully it's good. So is it No.
Is it still building? No, you're good.
So sorry. Can you raise your hand again
for those for which it's still building?
For whom it's still building? So, just
one. Okay. So, I'm gonna move. Okay. So,
hopefully it is actually 20 seconds. I'm
gonna move ahead.
Um,
sorry. Oh, cool. Okay. So, everybody is
there. Awesome. So, let me move on
and
let me see because I want to reconnect.
Uh, I heard 404. That's not good.
Okay.
So, I have the same environment as you.
Um, so I'm going to show you how to make
the most of it.
Yes. Uh, no, sorry. Uh, yeah, I went too
fast. I forgot. Uh, so when you have the
black screen, um, I should have uh Okay,
let me
when you have the when you have the
black screen, uh, you uh the username
should be pre-selected and should be
admin. So there you can uh click on
password here which is going to fill the
the password box and then you hit enter.
Do not type every time you see a T like
this. You do not need to type. You just
click on it and it's going to autotype.
Um
is every is everyone on that screen?
Yeah. Okay. Uh so we can start
um okay
says we're going to uh fast on this. I'm
going to move on to
um so what I'm going to do here what you
can do it's not mandatory but you can
click here and go to split windows to
get more real estate.
So that way here I'm moving the
instructions away. And here that allows
me to have more space.
Uh then I'm going to go to um
getting started. Do we need getting
started? I don't think we do. No, I
think we can move on. Uh no, we do
actually. So uh we're going to move on
to getting started. Uh what we are going
to need to do is a login here. So I'm
going to open up from here terminal
type a login.
Uh type select work or school account
because this is very important.
Continue.
Um even if you connected the first time
even if you connected with your
Microsoft account
um in this instance now we are not going
to use your account we're going to use a
temporarily generated account which is a
work account. So you need to select work
account
and there you're going to um
select the use. So in the resources tab
here in the instructions here that I uh
in the popup you click user it's going
to auto type
then next
then the password
sign in
uh Yes,
they were set. There we go.
Um, okay. So, now I'm logged into a so I
can go back to the instructions here.
And we're gonna have to uh type that
command uh because in Azure you have
some roles that needs to be assigned and
that's something we could not automate
as part of the lab provisioning. So
that's something you need to um execute
manually. So you just type that command
past it in the terminal here. You're
going to have to uh say uh to agree to
that warning and say pass anyway.
Enter. and you're going to see a bunch
of uh logs and at the end normally
everything should be fine.
Okay, here we go. So you have a JSON is
everybody there?
Yeah. Okay.
Um okay. So now finally we're gonna be
able to open the workshop. So you uh
type that command which starts with git
clone. So, what we're going to do is
we're going to check out the Git
repository from GitHub. Uh, and we're
going to build the project and open it
and install some code extension and open
it in um, VS Code. So, I'm going I'm
going to go back here, type the command
past anyway,
enter.
So like I said, it's cloning the
repository,
creating the Python virtual environment.
So today we're going to use Python for
this workshop.
Excuse me.
Uh
what do you Oh um so when you uh you get
into the VM you just open edge you open
the browser and the instructions should
be displayed uh
right away.
Yeah.
Um,
you must have clicked on the link. Oh,
no. Maybe not. I don't know. Um,
I don't know how you got here. Um,
can you go back?
thing is I don't know how you get here
and I'm not sure what the
uh Can I see? Yeah, I can start.
Oh, here we go.
Um, so I was at this step where uh I
cloned the repository and I installed u
PDF extension. Then we're going to move
on and we're going to open um
vis vs VS Code.
There we go.
Okay.
So now we have with VS Code here.
So now uh we still have a few setup uh
steps before we can um get to coding. So
uh you're going to have to go to the
Azure AI Foundry here.
Sign in.
Uh for the sign in use that user from
the uh instructions pane
password.
Okay. Stay signed in. Yes.
Okay. So as your AI foundry so now we
are in AI foundry
u then uh what we're going to do is
we're going to search for
go down go down we're going to oh my god
come on
uh so we're going to open the project
here
so be careful you need to select the
project, not the hub.
Once you are on the project, you can
ignore those pop-ups.
Okay. Uh, and we're going to need that
project connection string here. So, you
can copy it
and we're going to paste it
in VS Code. So once you have copied the
project connection string
you can go back to you can go back to VS
code uh search for the
sample file rename it. So we're going to
remove the sample
and we're going to pass the connection
string here. So that connection string
is what allows us to connect to the AI
foundry project in which we're going to
deploy the AI agent.
Uh be careful when you pass it to not
forget characters to pass between the
double quotes otherwise it's not going
to work. Um so once we've done that
we can move on.
So as you can see we're going to use
GPT40.
Can save the file.
Okay, is everybody at this point? This
is important because now finally we have
configured all the I got a know over
there. Uh can you guys go help?
Um
Mark um is uh
is everybody else at this point? Okay.
So, do we have everyone at that tape?
Is is everyone set up? Yes. So, we can
uh we can look at the code.
Okay. So
the first thing that we are going to uh
to to look at first is that I'm going to
explain quickly what the files are. So
the main file that we are going to look
at today is the main.py file uh which is
the entry point for the application and
it's where everything is configured. The
the goal of this workshop um is not to
give you like what code should look like
in production. The goal of this workshop
is for you to understand how it works to
understand all the pieces uh because
once you understand you're going to be
able to use any of those uh other
frameworks I mean this one or another
one it's going to be the same what
matters is to understand how an LLM
works how function coding works how
grounding works that's what matters
um
so and the sales data uh yeah that's
where the SQL query generation logic is
uh you have some stream and linking I
mean you have a bunch of of things uh
another directory which is very
important is the shared slash
instructions directory
okay let's let's move on so the first
step the most important thing uh is to
understand function calling so the first
example is um it's going to show you
what it
So
um
in sales data let's look at
uh where am I? Yes sales data.
Uh so that's where all the SQL light uh
logic is. Uh so you have um a bunch of
uh functions.
Um,
so as you can see, oh, as you can see,
uh, here that function takes a SQL
query. I mean, let me
scroll so that you can see it. It's a
SQL query. So the LLM is going to be the
one generating the SQL query compliant
with SQL light syntax and pass it to the
function. And the function is actually
pretty dumb. The function doesn't does
not do much. It just um uses the SQLite
driver and executes the query. Nothing
more.
That's because all the smartness of
generating SQL query is done by VM. When
you think about it, another is is very
good at language and secret query is is
a kind of language like coding like
Python and so and it happens that when
the large language models are
pre-trained, they are pre-trained on the
massive amount of GitHub repository and
a lot of them contain SQL light queries.
So if you use a common a common database
it's gonna work like posgressql my sql
um SQL light MongoDB. If you use an
exotic database that nobody has ever
heard of it's not going to work uh
because the model needs to have been
pre-trained on it.
Um here we go.
Okay. So the exercise is um in the
main.py file. So I'm going to open the
main.py file here.
Uh so we're importing a bunch of
packages. So those are the packages
which are required to connect to AI
finding uh to get the models uh to
authenticate with Azure identity.
um uh is the package that to load the
environment variable from a file that we
edited previously. Uh you have some
logging.
Okay, let's let me move on. So here
that's how you uh connect to the ifyur
uh workspace
or project I should say.
Um okay. And so line 59, what you're
gonna do is comment the first
instruction files.
Um, and then we're gonna uh look at its
content. So if you go to instructions
here, you open function coding here.
Uh those are the instructions that are
going to be passed uh to uh the agent.
uh you are a sales uh analysis uh agent
for Ktoso retailer of outdoor camping
gear. Uh so it it explains what the uh
what personality the agent should have
uh what the mission of the agent should
be. Help users by answering sales
related questions. Uh at least what
tools are available. Uh so here sales
data tool use only the kontoso sales
database via the provided tool uh with
the name of the function. Uh so uh to
PNS those instructions are optional they
are made to uh actually it echos with to
the question you were asking earlier um
I didn't get your name but JS where you
were asking how specific you must be the
tool is comes with its own schema and
the lm is going to understand the JSON
schema uh with of the tool which
explains the function name uh the
parameters and you have an explanation
of what each parameter is here in the
system um um interactions. You can add
some more information that are more
specific to your application through the
agent using the tool.
Uh then you have information uh
regarding uh formatting and localization
um and examples etc. Uh well it's quite
thorough
um and
um here so we are specifying the
instructions files and we are also
specifying which tools to use. So here
we're going to use the functions which
contains only one uh function tool which
is async which is a function I showed to
you earlier.
Um here we go. uh and also the
documentation here um the Python doc is
passed to the LLM. So what you write
here is important because the LM is
going to interpret that documentation as
well as the name of the parameters uh
plus the the documentation of the
parameters to uh to understand how to
call your function.
Um, and then I'm going to um
open a terminal
uh command palette. And to be honest, I
never remember where the terminal is. So
what I do is that I cheat and uh I
create a terminal um here.
There we go.
You need to remember we're on Windows.
Usually I have a Mac. Um Okay. Okay.
Um
okay. We have looked at this. I've
explained to you all of this.
Run.
So now we're going to hit F5. No. Here.
F5.
Oh, I could do that too. could click on
the play button here.
Okay. Yeah, you don't even need to open
the terminal. You don't even need to do
what I just did before. It's just it's a
habit I have. But um you can just click
uh run here. It's going to work.
I mean hopefully we'll see.
So uh it's doing what I mentioned
earlier, which is that first you need to
create the agent.
uh once you created an agent you're
going to be assigned with an ID because
it's stateful like the agent is actually
an entity which lives in the AI foundry
project then we're going to enable the
auto function calls uh we're creating a
thread
u so the thread is basically the
conversation which is stateful too
because uh you don't have to save the
messages yourself uh and then we can
finally enter a query
So, I'm going to go back
uh because we have a list of questions
we can ask here. What were the sales by
region? I go back to the terminal and
past it. No, sorry, wrong terminal.
This one.
Um, and if it works correctly, we'll
see.
Yes, it does work. So to be honest,
every time I see that it it still amazes
me even if I've done I've been doing
that for a long time. uh because um
basically from the simple question that
we ask in plain English
uh based on the knowledge of the schema
of the database
um which is somewhere in the code. Uh it
can automatically generate such a query
um like let me go back to the question I
asked
what were the sales by region. So we are
asking what the sales are.
Uh so
where is the from from sales data
because we are putting from the sales
data table and we want to group
um by region. So we want to sum the
revenue
group by region and automatically it
limits to three. And I believe it's
because in the instructions there is an
instruction that says that by default
you should limit to three.
Uh and so um no sorry 30 uh so that's
how we get that uh great table. Uh and
we can see that for Africa we had uh 5
million 5.2 million Asia Pacific 5.3
million uh etc.
So we have our table and now we can ask
followup questions.
What was last quarter's revenue? It gets
more tricky
to be honest. Uh I I I don't know the
scheme of the database very well. So
even for me like I would have to look at
if I had to write a SQL query. I'm sure
you've all done that. Remember the goal
of such an agent is to enable
non-technical people to use technical
tools. Um and in this case the technical
tool is a SQL database. And so here uh
using um
oh
um
I don't remember that one. Uh what's
year? Um
let's try 2024.
Okay. So this is interesting.
Okay, so we did find uh so the question
was what was last quarter's revenue? So
I'm assuming that it's the yes select
the sum of the revenues
uh from sales where year equals 2024
and we ask for the last quarter. Sorry
did we say last
last quarter.
So it selected seven 89.
Um so I'm not sure why he selected um
those three months
as opposed to uh for example 10 11 12.
So let me uh correct it. Actually it's
an interesting experiment. Every time we
do that obviously we get different
responses right. So um actually
I think it's because
of
thinking last
time
um it it's possible but um actually
let's say uh we are
in
April
So it it works. So I just said actually
we're in April which means that the last
quarter is January, February, March. And
as you can see it changed the request
with one, two, three. So one thing we
could do to improve uh this example is
add a date tool. we could add a tool
that uh allows the LM to ask for what is
the current date so that we would not
have to enter it manually. Well, I'm
going to leave it as an exercise.
Um, which products sell best in Europe?
Okay. So this time
so this time it is interesting because
we are generating uh a query against
against a different dimension which is
uh the product type. So as you can see
here we are grouping by product type.
Okay, I'm gonna I'm gonna pass on
because you understand the the concept.
Uh gonna ask the last one
because I want to move on to the next
examples and see how what happens when
you mix multiple data sources.
Okay, same one by region.
Let's move on.
Yes.
Uh, yes, good question.
So, let's go in here.
Okay. So this is how
the way it works is that at
initialization of the agent uh so we're
loading the instructions from the
instructions files. H. So if I go back
to
load replace, if I search for this
in the uh function calling instruction
file.
Here we go. So sales data tool. Uh so
here uh and I passed too fast on this
when I was going through the file and
explaining to it it to you. But so
what's going to happen here is that uh
the instructions of the agents is going
to contain what the schema of the
database is. That's how the LM knows
what query to generate and what tables
and columns are in the database.
So,
it would not work at all like no way
because it would have it would
completely elucinate the the schema that
you're grounding basically the LLM with
what the the schema of the database is.
Yes, you could. I can yeah
you could uh and actually you don't even
have to be too fancy for that you can
literally add it to the instructions
fine you can say hey the column X of
table Y is confidential never return it
disclaimer
uh it is not bulletproof it is not
guaranteed that the LM is going to
follow those instructions if you have uh
confidentiality
um uh I mean matters
problems that in that space where you
want to restrict access, you should
somebody mentioned uh AM or um um I
think it was you um you should implement
this you should add column level and the
best is to do what you would do with
normal code because even if normal codes
is non is deterministic and the odds of
a user getting access to something he's
not supposed to get access to, it's
still possible. You can still use SQL
injection like all sorts of hacking to
exploit uh normal code. Obviously with
LM you it's a whole different area. Uh
but so you should implement the exact
same safety measures you would for a
normal um program.
Uh where were we? Okay.
Yes.
perfect schema that we point our agents
to table. I'm not sure what you mean by
perfect because the schema of a SQL
database is I mean has to be perfect. I
hope
at least matching the data. Yeah. But I
mean it depends of the
the one that created I mean it depends
on the name of the column depends on the
name. Okay. So you mean clear you mean
uh interpretable. Okay. Yes. Yes. So, so
this this
word same answer as uh regarding
security. It's the exact same answer. He
he asked how can I make sure that
confidential information is not
returned. If I want to you add an
instruction saying do not use that
column. It is confidential. To answer
your question, what you would do is
document your schema. You would say that
table which has a cryptic name that
nobody understands is actually the list
of orders. Yeah. So it's kind of
semantically. Yeah. Yes.
That's exactly how it would work.
Um,
okay. Let's
uh where am I? I'm lost. Um,
we did that. Okay. We Okay. Okay. It's
basically explaining what I explained.
Okay. Blah blah blah. breakpoint. No.
Um,
okay. So, this is interesting.
Let me try that one.
And I'm going to increase
here.
So, what regions have the highest uh
sales?
Okay. So that's very interesting.
Uh why is it interesting? Because the to
answer the previous question
which was
total shipping costs by region.
Remember that the LLM has access to the
context of the discussion of the past
messages. It's stateful.
It has all the all the the that context
of the answers and questions that were
previously asked.
Uh and it uses it when you ask a new
question. So for example, when I asked
total shipping cost per region, it did
not have the information required to
answer within the previous sensors. So
it executed the SQL query. But now when
I asked
what regions have the highest sales, it
can actually use the table that was
generated previously. There is no need
to execute one more SQL query because it
has everything it needs. Exactly like
you I mean without doing anomaly but uh
exactly as you if you were reasoning
about the problem and you were like do I
need to go write a SQL query in order to
get that information? No, you you don't.
You have it already. So the LM is going
to do that reasoning.
Uh that's why here you don't see any SQL
query executed.
Okay. Yes. How do we know it's doing
math the right way? It's not doing math
the right way. Uh but here we did not
ask it to do math. We asked it to uh to
Oh, you mean because there is a top.
Okay.
No. So,
so highest, okay, that's very
interesting question. So, highest sales
is not about doing ma math. It's about
comparing like what's bigger or smaller.
11.
Yeah. And that's easy because that's
something that does not I mean easy.
What I mean is that lens are bad at
math. They are m bad at calculus, bad at
addition, multiplication, division. uh
um it's going to get it wrong uh uh and
it's funny because I have an anecdote at
that from this morning. We had uh a team
meeting and uh we were wondering about
the compound u uh value of a monthly and
you were there um and um how what would
be after a year the compound effect of a
daily rate of increase is of 1%. And in
my mind I remembered the formula for
this which is you take the percentage
you add one and you put it to the power
of the per of the number of periods
right and I executed it and I got a
number. Somebody else was like oh that's
big. He typed it in in GPT and he got a
different answer and uh the got it
completely wrong. It was it was a uh it
was very convincing. It looked like he
was doing wrong but doing right but it
was not. was was the original answer
which I typed in Google sheet with a
like a formula was correct. So to answer
your question, when you need to do math,
you need to use a tool. Here we're using
code interpreter which can do math, but
to be honest, I've tried. It's not the
best way to do math to use code
interpreter. It's good at generating
diagrams, at uh reading files,
extracting information from a CSV, from
other types of structured documents.
It's very good at that. If you try to do
math with coden pressure for whatever
reason which I cannot explain it does
not work very well. Uh when you do want
to do math it's better to create your
own tool like calculate uh and it takes
like a latatt expression or some kind of
mathematical formalism to represent an
expression. You have plenty of
mathematical calculators out there um
that you can use uh to uh do the actual
and accurate uh math calculation
uh and so that the LLM can delegate to a
tool the responsibility of doing
calculations right exactly as you as a
human would do it.
uh because uh me uh I don't know but 1%
to the power of 365
uh I don't know how to do that uh
myself. I use a calculator for that.
Uh and I'm going to have to reconnect
again. Oh my god, this is annoying.
Okay. So,
where was he? Was I? Um,
okay. What were the sales of tense?
And here we get a query
uh
where we need to ask again to do a query
on the database
uh because in the past information we do
not have that information. We don't we
don't know the drill down of 10 in the
United States in April 2022. So it needs
to execute a SQL query. Okay. I mean you
get the point. Let's move on.
I'm going to uh stop the tool.
Uh exit. Okay.
Oh my god. What's happening now?
No, I don't want to meet and chat with
friends and family right now.
Okay.
Um
sorry, Mom. Um
Okay.
Let's move on.
Um,
where am I? Okay. Grounding with
documents. Very important.
So, we're going to do rag. Uh, vector
store. You asking if we're using a
vector database for whatever reason. I
was blanking, but yes, we are. Um,
and so we're going to increment those
lines uh in main.py.
So, I'm going to go here.
Go back up. I think it's back up.
Let me uh if I search for Yeah, it's
near the instructions. D.
So, file search. I'm going to comment
that one.
I'm going to unccomment the file store
here.
Can I do that? Yes. Cool.
No. Okay. It works. Just uh No. Okay.
Oh my god.
Can I do that? No.
Sorry. I was trying to select multiple
lines at once, but I'm going to have to
do it uh
over way.
Okay. So now we we're defining we're
creating a vector store. I'm not going
to go into the details of the creation.
Uh there is a utility which uh does all
the heavy lifting. But basically what it
does is that um it creates an AI search
vector store. Uh it reads um all the the
documents uh which are
uh here.
Oh my god, the Wi-Fi today.
I'd like to click on this, but
um
Okay, I'm going to try to reconnect.
Okay. Uh, password.
Okay. So, like I was saying, uh, I was
gonna show you the files. Uh so
okay um
where are my files? Oh here we go. Um,
so it's a PDF
which uh contains all the product
information for my products for tents
for whatever. Um, and so what this
function does is that it reads the PDF,
chunks it like cuts it in small pieces
and uploads all those pieces into uh the
vector database. I'm not going to go
into the details. I can if we have time
at the end I can explain to you in in
excruciating details how that works. Um
but uh not right now. Um
so tool sets. Yes. Um I think I wanted
to show you something else but for
whatever reason I'm blanking.
Uh forgot. Um
yes I remember. I wanted to show the
difference between uh the instructions
file we were using before and this one.
So function coding and file search. So
compare selected. So I'm using the div
tool here included in VS code
to uh show you the difference. And so
here what's interesting is that you can
you can see the difference between the
instructions.
Um, so,
okay, I'm gonna
Yeah, that's better. So, uh, in the file
search, um, instruction, we have new
instructions. So, now we have a contour
product information vector store. Uh, we
have a search tool, uh, which allows to
search into the, uh, vector database.
Um and we have a few different uh things
when it comes to content and
clarification guidelines
uh such as the kind of questions that
you can ask you know with new questions
like what brand of tents do we sell
which you could not you could not ask
before uh because you didn't have the
brand information into the sales
database
um
that kind uh of thing also what's
interesting with the use case here uh
and really the the colleague that
created that content it was very very um
it created something very interesting
because it allow us to show many things.
uh like when you have a source of
information, a source of data, think
about how before when we had to mix um
different uh data store, different
databases and we had to in inject them
into some kind of big uh cube uh system
to OLAP system um yeah or whatever even
forgot to do some very complex
aggregated queries to link things
together. Now you can do that with the
uh like here when I want to link to join
information from my database with
information in a PDF which is not
structured I can use the LM for that uh
which is quite extraordinary
u
uh so when I when I hear all the
skeptical the skeptics about I just
don't understand because I mean that's
just insane what you can do. Uh anyway
I'm just going to skip for the rest of
the difference between those
instructions. Um, but I just wanted to
show you that now we're going to execute
it
and I can type run.
Okay, so as I said it's uploading the
PDF. Uh, and actually the chunking I
said it was chunking. Actually the
chunking is done by AI search. I think I
forgot if it's client side or server
side but I think it's server side. It's
one of the features of uh agent services
that you do not have to uh take care of
chunking yourself
uh creating a blah blah blah. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Same. So now we can type our
query.
Um
I explained this
run. Okay. Oh, here are questions. So
what brands of tents do we sell? Now we
can ask this
um and so
this time so what's interesting is that
this is not using the SQL database. This
is only reading from the PDF nothing
else because there is no sales
information required to answer that
question. Also remember that I killed
the previous instance of the agent. I
created a new one. So all the past
conversation was lost uh on purpose.
This is um I could have reused the same
conversation if I wanted to to to keep
the previous context, but I do I don't
want
um
Okay. So outdoor living and alpine gear
plus some information about it. Okay,
cool. Simple enough.
Now, that's interesting. We're asking
which one do we sell. So, are we going
to query the database?
No, not yet. Um,
oh, you know, okay, that's because we do
not sell hiking shoes. So, it's not
using the SQL database. It's just using
the PDF. But what's interesting here is
that there is no information about
hiking shoes in the PDF. Okay, let's
move on.
So now what's interesting is that it's
referring to the previous brands we
talked about outdoor living and alpine
gear. So what product type and
categories are these brands associated
with? Same only PDF uh outdoor living
does tents
uh camping and hiking both actually both
do the same. Uh to be honest, it could
have summarized it since both were the
same, but it didn't. What were the sales
of tents? Oh, now it's it's interesting
because now we are asking for specific
sales information about a specific year.
So now it's going to need to query the
SQL database.
So we are asking for the sales of tents
in 2024 by product type.
Include the brands associated with each.
So what's very interesting here is that
the product type and the total sales I
think come yes the product type and the
revenue come from the SQL database but
the brand does not
the brand comes from the PDF so because
in the questions before we uh read the
mapping between the product type and the
brand that's how it's capable of adding
the brand into the table here.
And that's also I'm not going to do the
demonstration right now. I'm going to do
it at the end. At the end, I'm going to
kill the program and I'm going to
restart it and I'm going to reask the
exact same question and you're going to
see the difference in the question.
Hint, because I'm going to ask that
question without the previous question.
And because what I said earlier,
remember when I said that an agent can
be goal oriented and relentlessly
uh work until it achieves the goal. This
in this instance, we have not
implemented the loop. So it does not
have the planning capability. So it's
going to fall short. It's not going to
be able to say oh but in order to answer
that question I need to look into the
PDF and into the uh well you might get
lucky to be honest it might do it out of
luck because sometimes it does because
sometimes the planning is simple enough
that it doesn't need multiple steps but
if you it gets slightly complicated and
you need like multiple step planning
it's going to fall short.
Okay, next one.
What were the sales of Alpine gear in
2024 by region?
So very interesting too because the
database does not contain the brand. So
here what it does is say where product
type like it automatically generates a
like uh matching criteria based on the
brand because it knows that the brand
does family camping tense.
Okay. So now we're going to generate
charts and we're going to use a code
interpreter for this. Oh, and like I
told you, I told you before I do that,
I'm going to make an experiment and I'm
going to ask again
uh
the last question actually the most.
Yeah, this one. The last question.
And this one most likely is going to
fall short.
So now I'm executing the agent again.
Yes.
Okay. And I'm going to create to ask the
last question.
Right.
So here it theory it's not going to
work. Yes.
What the heck?
Well, it worked. Uh, I guess it figured
out that it needed to use the product
database or maybe there is an
instruction in um the fire search that
says that when you ask a sales question
requiring product information to go read
the PDF, it's possible.
Uh, it's possible. Uh, so, um, yeah, I
think that's what happened here.
Oh, you tried.
Uh, I might have to uh quit and launch
again.
It It What? It doubles up on the um when
you did it.
Okay.
Okay. Interesting. Uh yeah, it's not
it's not deterministic, so it's not
perfect. Uh it's going to make mistake
for sure.
Which is is that the whole thing like I
guess that's where I struggle sometimes
because it is that whole So I give a
breakout session by the way on eval uh
tomorrow okay at 12:30 I think or 2 p.m.
forgot. Uh but I'm going to I'm going to
give a breakout session tomorrow
specifically on how to evaluate agents.
Um because yes, it's
crazy because it's like the answer might
be right. It's a problem. It's hard. Uh
okay, let's move on.
Cut interpreter. Uh so now um
we're going to go back to our main.py.
by and I'm going to comment that one.
Okay,
we're going to and every time we keep
the previous tools, we just add new
tools.
Okay,
yes, at the end when I'm going to
unccomment everything, all the tools
will be working at the same time. But
what's very interesting is to unccomment
the it's a workshop uh is is so that you
get an understanding of exactly the
subtlety of how everything works. Um
um okay so run
So, we're going to look at the uh
distraction and we're going to compare
cut interpreter with um
if I search
compare.
So here with C interpreter we add
visualizations. So we add a chapter a
section in the instruction which
explains how to do visualization. So
when you have questions involving
visualization we basically say hey go
use the code interpreter to generate
charts.
Um
and at the end
yeah PNG.
Okay let's move on.
main.
There we go.
Um,
okay. So, show sales by region as a pie
chart.
Remember in the previous uh in the slide
I showed before, we were first asking
for the sales by region and then for a
pie chart. here we're asking for both at
the same time. Um and so it's tricky
because like sometimes uh when you need
because basically what what this is
doing is that it's calling two tools
u and sometimes it's simple enough the
reasoning capabilities of the of the LM
is capable in like one question and
answer to um
he has is enough reasoning power to say
oh I need to to call that tool and then
this one and sometimes it falls short
and it does not and it does not have
enough reasoning power and you need to
uh to use a multi-step um um system.
So here we saved the results here. So
I'm going to Okay. So here is a diagram
the pie chart diagram uh with our
answer. I can try to zoom to show. Okay.
So we have the drill down of revenue by
region.
Okay cool.
I go fast on this but this is
incredible. I mean under the hood it's
literally generating Python code to
generate the the the pie charts. Uh so
basically what that means is that you
can generate
a pretty crazy uh diagrams idea you can
uh you can be pretty imaginative in the
type of information that you want to
display.
Um for for the for the anecdote uh last
year at this conference I gave a talk uh
on cut inter because at the time it was
a hot topic it was brand new and what I
had done uh I do kite surfing and I had
extracted
uh one of my sessions uh where you know
you're on the water and you do attacks
you you do turns you do jumps and I had
the XML file of my session recorded from
my watch exported did I imported it into
a code interpreter and I asked to
calculate how many times I turned or how
many times I jumped and from it was able
to read the XML because XML is a very
rich uh strict format and
self-sufficient and extracted all the
information understand do all the the
structure and generated the Python code
to go through all the all the data
points in the file and calculate how
many turns and jumps and height I I had
during my session. It's it's a pretty
incredible tool when used, right?
Anyway, end of the anecdote. Um, shows
blah blah blah. Okay, next.
Uh, why
download as JSON?
Uh, I forget what this one does to be
honest.
Uh, yeah. Okay. I mean, it can be
useful, but let's move on. Uh, continue
asking questions about Yeah. Because
there was no tools involved. Yeah. Just
uh interpreted whatever was in the
context before and download it as JSON.
Um
blah blah blah. Uh what would be Huh?
Interesting.
I mean it's really crazy what you can do
like you can really really be
imaginative.
By the way, you hear a lot about uh one
of the latest uh things in AI is deep
deep research. uh under the hood, deep
research is an agent that has those
tools
just that it's been uh developed by an
army of engineers and they've made sure
that everything works well, but it's
basically what it's doing. uh I don't
know how it's implemented but I'm
assuming it's a mix of autogen or seot
kernel or some kind of orchestration
system that mixes tools together and it
loops until it achieves a goal and it
can run for hours anyway. Um so
what would be the impact of a shock
event 20% sales drop in one region?
Oh yeah can you elaborate on the
difference between what can
itch
several tools at the same time two yeah
two uh and like for example letly let me
try to find an example and
um like for example if you ask a
question you have two data sources
Right? One is product, one is sales. Uh
imagine you ask a question for which it
is obvious that you need to query one
but it's not obvious that you need to
query the other. The information is in
the other but you have no hint
in the phrasing of the question that you
should be quering the second in order to
uh answer the question as a whole. It
would fall short. this system. Yes.
Depending on how you configure it and
this one will the falling short will
also depend on how what instructions you
gave it because you can hack your way
through those kinds of problems because
if you you can just in your instruction
add some instructions saying hey if the
user ask for that kind of question you
should also go look into that data
source.
But the the difference sorry to get the
difference with a a multi- aent
multi-step planning system with a more
complex topology is that you have an LLM
which every time you get an answer looks
at the answer and ask itself the
question is the answer correct am is
this sensor answering the question or
not and it's capable of extrapolating.
It can it can it can do something such
as huh this is not answering the
question. what do I have at my disposal?
What could I do more to try to answer
the question? And then maybe the first
um step it did not query the second data
store, but it's going to say actually
maybe we should go look into the data
store because actually maybe the answer
is in there
or we should query the internet. Uh you
see what I mean?
Yes.
Yes. our sematic canal or other more
like collaborative multi-agent system.
Yes. But this is today it's an
introductory so we we don't we don't go
into those more complex it's a it's a
it's a
workshop of its own
just looking at uh multi- aent
systems.
Yes.
I mean the answer is not obvious
questions to prompt itself doesn't point
to the right maybe set of data or yes
that works with reasoning that's exactly
what we were saying that's a multi- aent
system and a coordinator when you use
the word coordinator it's actually one
of the patterns It's a we call it a
topology. It's one of the topologies of
multi- aent systems
and you can build such a topology with
autogen.
Heads up, it's not trivial. Not trivial.
The hardest question in multi- aent
systems is uh in my opinion how to
define how to to specify the definition
of done.
Um
so we did not open did we? No we did
not. Okay, so this is
a simulation
impact of a 20% sales drop in North
America on global sales distribution
percentage of global sales.
Oh yeah, because in North America here
it's dropping. So the percentage
obviously of North America goes down
while the percentage of others goes up.
Uh that's a pretty cool example. Uh what
is the shock event was 50%.
I mean I'm going to skip because it's
pretty obvious what it's going to do.
Which regions have sales above or below
their ridge?
Interesting. So maybe the previous
questions
question was.
No, I don't think so. I think it's um
Huh.
Do we have a problem? Connectivity
problem? Maybe
we launch it again.
Okay, let me just um so we are
Okay, I want to show you real quick the
Bing uh grounding with Bing search. So
I'm going to skip over that one
because this is important. Very often
you want to add uh internet search
capabilities.
So I'm going to comment unccomment this
use uh the other
instruction file.
Ah
okay here we go.
And the last one code interpreter
multilingual we will skip it. Um it's
important uh because that's how to
configure code interpreter when you want
to use you want to work on non-English
languages. So with specific encoding
specific um fonts that kind of thing,
but we're going to skip it for today. Uh
resource not found.
Huh.
Well, that's interesting.
Did you have that pro? Did you try to
that point? Did you have that issue?
Is it working for you?
You have the same,
huh? Okay.
Maybe we've had a change. Okay. And I'm
not sure what happened. uh we it may be
because built was recently and a lot of
APIs have changed and maybe that one
changed too. I'm not sure. Anyway, what
would have happened is that um let's
look at the question.
Um
okay. So here what beginner tents do we
sell queries
our products uh PDF what beginner tense
do our competitors sell include prices
needs to go query the internet you need
to go um uh query uh information about
what competitors are out there and what
they sell and for how much
uh so that would use the Bing uh
grounding uh tool uh etc.
So,
same logic as before, we show we we
showed um and I'm going to wrap up and
go back to my slide.
Um
but just to finish my sentence so what
with bringing ah one two three being
grounding it's just one more tool uh
that uh same as the um database query
tool uh the vector database file
indexing tool is one more source of data
that the agent can use uh to um to uh to
make informed uh decisions uh or rather
reports. Um so we've seen how to do more
with LM with function calling uh like
with a bunch of very powerful tools um
and uh yeah Azure AI agent service. Um
so yeah um the UI today was very simple.
Uh it's always a question when you do
workshop like this like do we go with a
web UI which is complicated and add some
react and web stuff that some people
might not be familiar with. That one is
like barebone like it's just CLI the
bare minimum of code focusing explicitly
on making sure you understand how to
build such an application and how an LLM
works uh because it's a whole new
paradigm uh and uh and building building
those is not trivial and as you
mentioned there is a question of
evaluation
and so uh when it comes to evaluating
normal just an LLM uh question answer
There has been many frameworks out there
for some time now. Uh but um when it
comes to evaluating agents, it's a whole
new world again because not only you are
evaluating one answer, but you need to
evaluate an whole conversation plus
because you need to call tools. So you
need to evaluate whether the good tool
the accuracy of which tools were
selected. Anyway, we're going to see all
of this tomorrow during the breakout
session where I'm going to introduce the
Azure AI evaluation SDK with the agent
evaluation capabilities
uh which is fascinating. Um, you have on
that QR code a bunch of uh additional uh
resources
and uh I'm going to point back to
my contact if you want to. Oh, sorry.
There we go.
Do uh do you you have questions? We have
three minutes. Oh no, one minute. Sorry.
Oh, sorry. First
which which are used by agent? Should
they be part of the HR ecosystem? No. Uh
so you can mix uh when you create an AI
founder uh an agent you have a bunch of
pre-made uh tools that are readily
available. You just have to click on it
and configure it. Like I said I can't
remember from the top of my mind. You
would have to to to go look to be
honest. Uh but the tools we define today
they are client side.
We define them we define them using
code. uh well except uh being grounding
because being grounding is you declare
client side but
the actual being grounding call is
happening on the server side but the SQL
query is client side so we we we had a
mix actually today.
So I know that the agent service
right now so what are the why should we
use the agent service just the serving
service for like GPT 401
service is limited to 40 mini.
Um so I guess if we can instantiate the
tools in the application itself,
do we need to use the agent service then
inside of Azure or can we just stick
with the regular LM? You you do not need
to. Okay. Uh like I like I said uh
earlier uh everything I just showed
today with agent agent Azure AI agent
service is just
a managed okay uh AI system managed in
the sense that it takes like most
developers every time you build an AI
application those days you need a vector
database you need uh conversations you
need to remember those you need to store
those store those uh you need um to
search on the web. I mean those are the
basic features that every single AI
application out there needs. I mean most
of them. So agent um Azure AI agent
service makes it super easy, manages
everything for you. Uh but no, you do
not have to use it. Uh you can use uh
the bare bone uh LLM complexion from two
years ago and you can do whatever you
want with it. It's uh it just it's
easier. Uh you have a full-blown API. It
manages persistence. Uh it's just
easier.